there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
hey here we are it's friday night
everybody
yeah holy [ __ ] everybody got your
[ __ ] drinks and snacks and
i know everybody's in there already
talking bee's nest is in there
bee's nest is uh my boy's he works in
mexico so he's
crossing the border and teal with
tijuana all the time i love that uh i
love that shirt you sent by the way yeah
he said jenny's
because i wore it like last week i don't
know if he saw it or not he'll send me
down
he's in there saying he came off a
three-day vendor in the damn hotel with
the girls
he's got pictures to prove too he's not
[ __ ] around
he'll say hey i haven't been saying
anything about his i don't i don't know
you know [ __ ] how how much he wants
to keep his channel
down low but he'll send me send me a
book
he'll send me on [ __ ] messenger and
[ __ ] videos of [ __ ] going in and down
[ __ ]
i don't want to call a brothel just
plays with a bunch of girls [ __ ]
waiting around to do business but he's
like should i get that one let me get
this one
let me get let me get that one yeah yeah
i'm like yeah get that one
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna say just a pro tip if you
want to keep anything on the download
don't tell tom about it
well if he tells me and [ __ ] his
messages you know he's talking about it
in public then i guess
i guess he's not you know he's not
trying well that's what i was going to
say it's not like he's trying to hide it
because he did post about it on youtube
because our answers are proved he's
showing me
right so it's like obviously he's not
going to be bothered if we mention it
i'm sure
more people will see it on his youtube
channel that'll see this
anyway [ __ ] it bismuth says
i have receipts you got receipts yeah
well that's good you need that [ __ ] for
like you know for tax purposes i'm in a
relationship i can't [ __ ] around
[Laughter]
why is it somebody asking you to no
but it's kind of like you know i mean
come on down man come on down i'll take
you come on man this is the south
carolina
all the hookers yeah yeah you know
you know how it is this guy's you guys
though got stuff
it still counts though see that's still
cheating
it is yeah that's still cheating some
people might not think so but there's
like you know there's there's that kind
of
there's that there's that whole line
where like some people kind of yeah i
don't know it's a whole spectrum of like
well
jen goes in on it with me she's like you
know i mean she's [ __ ] we're going 50
50. she gets one and i get the other
that's not necessarily not necessarily
cheating
well no i think that's not that's not
that's not jenny's type though that's
not jenny's type
yeah yeah you gotta pay jenny's not
interested
yeah that's like come on now she's got
her own prowess
yeah oh my gosh it's emotional women
it's emotional
well you know like i'm saying you got to
like like the person because i think we
were
we were talking about this i mean i was
pretty wasted on the wednesday show but
i think we were talking about
um unless i just thought it i think we
were talking about how
um dudes like if you don't like a girl
but she's hot you can still [ __ ] her
okay yeah a lot of i don't know if this
is true i'm sure it's not true of all
women because nothing is
yeah but i can't really like if i don't
like a dude
it doesn't really matter what he looks
like i still just i can't get into it
i can't get into it you know what i mean
he could be like the hottest dude in the
world but it's just kind of like if i
don't like him as a person it's just not
it's far easier to have sex with a woman
who's attractive and you don't like
than a woman you like and who isn't
attractive
if she's not attractive you just it's
just not going to happen
it's just it's because you know our our
system is so
kind of primitive it's all visual you
know so it doesn't matter
it's more about how they look yeah yeah
but that doesn't that's not doesn't have
anything to do with the relationship you
know i'm talking about
yeah because i guess we just kind of
evolved to be able to [ __ ] procreate
with females that we don't have
relationships with
yeah it's like i'm gonna impregnate that
one yeah yeah right right now and then
yeah
all of them it's pure biology it's like
something fish do
you know what i mean or frog
i'm gonna spray my heat all over the
ocean yeah
you stay here y'all stay here
i'm gonna go over there i'm gonna let it
all out
and it's gonna fall on y'all all right
and y'all gonna get pregnant
and my boy's gonna be next to me doing
the same thing it's going to be both of
us together getting all you all pregnant
it's going to be some [ __ ] like that
it's just weird like what i didn't know
was supposed to rain today
little frogs and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i just had like a really really funny
like mental picture
yeah of you as kind of like a fish or of
you also like spraying
things for frog stop yeah that's gross
well hey you started it
who's in here oh suddenly it's a group
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's kind of just comedic timing okay
see you there buddy down says not in my
pool yeah
right got mango in there got mango
badger in there bee's nest
amanda's there tila's in
i think women would mostly prefer to
forgive some physical flaws rather than
[ __ ] a hot [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah that it i think that is
the key yeah most of the time like i
said obviously not everybody yeah
i don't speak for we have standards
[Laughter]
it's not just human females it's all
females from most of them species are
like that most you're
like i said we have to be more
discerning yeah well they're choosing
which
one they're which one they're going to
carry the child with
who's going to give the most [ __ ] uh
resources that kind of stuff especially
with the higher primates
so it matters more yeah well like i said
dudes can just like you know
[ __ ] forget but you know we don't
really have that luxury so you know we
have to be a lot more picky
although i've known some chicks that
weren't all that picky dudes can have
children that they don't even know about
yeah which is crazy yeah a woman can't
have a child
[Laughter]
where did that come from yeah you can
have children they don't even know about
me that's very rarely happens
i have heard of like some clueless girls
that didn't know they were pregnant
yeah but obviously that when they found
out you know they were like oh
okay that's that's how that works no mom
never told me yeah
you know just theoretically
theoretically it's possible [ __ ] in
korea or brazil or any of these other
places that i wasn't there for very long
it could be theoretically as possible
but the chances are no
you know the chances are no chances are
no that's another like classic thomas
yeah yeah chance is not but you know
it's what i don't know you never know
you never know you don't know
[Laughter]
it would be really funny if i don't know
would it be funny it'd be kind of weird
if like somebody that was like [ __ ]
some 30 year old showed up on our
doorstep one day i was like dad
you're like who the [ __ ] are you kid my
best friend my best friend was like that
yes uh yeah his mom knew who the dad was
but she only she only met him once
it was kind of an accident yeah it
happened i mean
and there's no way to find him she
didn't remember what his name was
like i said yes and and the thing about
it too is that even
well and even if you're uh you know on
birth control you're on the pill or
something like that they're not
100 effective what is it 98 99 they're
still that little niggling one percent
yeah you never know so you know be
careful out there
that's all i'm saying uh so yeah the
show
tonight is about the phoenix lights tom
is so excited
been waiting for this show yeah and i
was kind of glad too it's like even
though
i'm not as into the ufo uh topics
but i know tom likes to do them and a
lot of people like them yeah a lot of
people have asked me when we're going to
do this because i think we did
we did it like another kind of black
triangle ufo kind of thing right
it was like the illinois one a long time
ago a lot that was a long time ago yeah
that was our older format too
yeah um but i was like i think at the
time i was kind of like cranky about
well then i want to do the phoenix
lights because it's like too well known
and
we should like do some stuff that's not
as well known but so that's kind of like
now now that
it's like later on we're we're doing
like all these
while we're doing all these better known
cases like serial killers and stuff like
that just because when we were first
starting out we wanted to
we wanted to kind of cover like
lesser-known [ __ ] yeah
when actually stuff that's better known
actually gets more hits the lesser known
stuff
well yeah because i mean the fact that
it's lesser known yeah it's like people
don't know to look for it right you know
what i mean that's why it's lesser known
well we were trying to stand out from
the competition at the time you know i
mean so people were looking for specific
cases they'd fight us
yeah and i thought it's like well i i
wanted to find like a little bit of a
niche because i was kind of like well
you know
everybody's covered jeffrey dahmer
everybody's covered you know this case
or whatever
and it's like so i wanted to find like
some different [ __ ] to do that wasn't as
you know yeah that wasn't as known i was
trying to be a hipster i guess
do we uh have any shout outs or anything
like that to do
i just have one okay and that is to our
beloved patron black marigold who has
increased support this week thank you
very
very
much thank you very much tbriggers asked
is the betty and bernie hill abduction
on the list for the future
it is we will get around to doing that
one of these days i think we probably
like talked about it
a little we haven't really done that
many ufo shows now that i'm thinking
about it
yeah i don't know like i said i kind of
get crabby but excellent they're all the
same but you know what i mean
it's an interesting case it's not a real
good case
well the best cases always involve air
forces
we could bundle it in with other cases
though that might be kind of interesting
real good cases always always involve
militaries with a bunch of witnesses
and um um you know
ground radar confirmation and uh you
know
governments and and governments involved
in it trying to figure out what it was
and corporations you know involved in it
too
um to try to you know say no that wasn't
a research craft or not could have been
you know [ __ ] like that and that you
know there's evidently some new
new tic tac ufo reports are going to be
coming out soon
and uh people are pretty excited about
them you know a little bit of it has
leaked already
and oh what's his name uh marco rubio
said something
uh and uh said something to the media
about it and
gave a general description of what it
was a little tic tacs about the size of
a damn air
of a fighter aircraft flying around
above a battle area
a battle uh carrier group um
for over like a week they could pick
them up on radar they could see them
every now and then then they got down
low
uh down to you know about the about the
hot about the same level of the command
bridge
near you know i think they said about a
mile out you could see them they were
trying to catch them with airplanes
aircraft
it's weird whatever it is and they said
that they were defying
physics you know making right angle
turns they didn't seem to have any
inertia involved in it
if it's but but it was there they were
getting radar returns off of it so it
was
it was a solid object it wasn't some
kind of a hologram or anything
and there were lots of them interacting
with aircraft
as if they were ai at least or possibly
you know possibly
and you know i i don't think they're ai
i think they're intelligent i don't
you know intelligent machines probably
i think it's extraterrestrial i don't
think it's i don't think it's chinese
i don't think the chinese could do it
but um
this case here the phoenix lice case i
remember when it happened
that was back in the day when i was
living in mississippi gulf coast
i was out of the army for a couple years
actually i just come back from boston
i guess it's in the late 90s when this
[ __ ] happened
it was at 98 97 97 yeah
having a good time i was with my first
wife and we were uh
going to the french quarter a lot it was
a good time
um this [ __ ] here
was weird man weird and it was all over
the news
and the governor and everything was
involved and you weren't
you weren't really sure what to believe
you know what i mean back in those days
because you couldn't get enough
information and they didn't really want
to talk about it
yeah this was kind of like before the
internet was a widespread thing yeah it
was around but it just wasn't good it
wasn't that good yet
and um i was impressed with this case
just too many people dabs too many damn
people saw it
yeah involved the thing about it is that
while i reserve judgment on whether it's
extraterrestrial or not
um that people saw something
obviously people saw something unusual
because
this you know how many hundreds people
like reported this over like [ __ ]
three states
evidently thousands of people saw it and
and
and thousands of people called into
9-1-1 dispatch saying that they were
seeing this thing
as it was going across the straits and
the calls were coming in
from where it would be at that time yeah
and people are
coming down yeah so
it wasn't a hoax they were seeing
something
now five symington the the governor uh
he
i think it was arizona saw it isn't it
wasn't it arizona yeah
he saw it he he eventually admitted to
seeing it
took him like ten years yeah and you
know they're kind of trying to bait him
yeah
it's funny how all these uh you know
secret aircraft you know they're trying
to
the the the interviewer's a real douche
bag he's trying to push him down that
wow all the crazy things we have and
simon's is kind of like uh
no no no yeah he's no
because it just said the goddamn thing
was huge um now i do have one theory of
what it could be
if it was terrestrial but i'll get into
that later
um well the thing about this one too is
that if you okay so if you do a search
on phoenix lights or if you watch a
documentary on the phoenix lights
a lot of the footage that they're
showing of the phoenix lights
is not the phoenix it's not the phoenix
light no um because there were
apparently two
separate incidents that happened over
the same night
and the one that happened later that
everybody got footage of
was not what the first people were
reporting from hours before
there's hardly any footage and it may or
may not be flares
the the the other one to me from the
video footage i've seen that they
show say this is the phoenix lights i'm
looking at it it doesn't look like
flares
to me but it also is not that it's not
it's not the the craft either whatever
it is
um you see i've seen many flyers
artillery flares m203 flares are
launched out of a [ __ ] m203
i've seen flares uh [ __ ] uh dropped
out of aircraft before
um a-10s uh mostly
mostly they were the flares that uh to
throw off ir
missiles or infrared heat-seeking
missiles i've seen those
but i've also seen them just dropping
down illumination flare to help some
guys on the ground
this is back before night vision was
real good you know
um flares don't look like that
you see a ball of light and then above
the ball like you see a trail of smoke
where it's falling and you can also see
the parachute a lot even at night
and the the intensity of of the burn
of those flares it's a white light and
it flickers and
uh it moves around that does not
look like like a flare whatever that is
but it's also not that other thing it it
i think it might be an airplanes flying
in formation
it could be a flare maybe it's just the
video quality so bad you can't see the
trail of smoke
yeah that's what i'm thinking it's like
so the second thing that has most of the
photos and videos of it and like i said
the footage that turns up in a lot of
documentaries about it
is not actually what the first witnesses
described
okay that was from like a couple hours
later they've done a lot of tests and
they've seen well look they're
disappearing one after the other they're
disappearing
and the video was taken from this
location and they're disappearing
and if you were to superimpose where the
skyline of the mountain ridge is they're
falling behind it's something falling
behind the mountain
range yeah that's the uh sierra
australia yeah
mountains yeah so they're not going out
they're falling out they're falling
behind the mountain range that was very
plausible saw a guy reenact that
they could have been flares but
from the naked eye with the naked eye
flares don't look like that but maybe
they
would look like that through low quality
vhs video
that's what i'm saying it's like so hard
to gauge
because it just seems like this is why
kind of a lot of ufo cases even kind of
famous ones
like whenever i see they're like look
and they put the video on youtube of
what they saw and i'm like that
looks like nothing it just looks like a
light that literally could be anything
well we're gonna as we get into the case
jenny will describe it and i'll probably
give you the order in which things
happened
to me my research of the case what
happened was people saw something they
couldn't explain they called to the cops
it was a mass
sighting uh they got a lot of details
from the witnesses
and then a few hours later the air force
went up and dropped some flares
and then got on the news saying oh now
you guys just saw flares so what they
did is they did a psyop
to [ __ ] cover up to confuse the case
and cover up what had happened it's very
easy to confuse a case
you know they saw lights in this guy
okay get up there and drop some flares
yeah you guys just saw flares yeah we
were just dropping flares yeah but it
was hours later
yeah it was like two hours later right
which means that
um the air force knew about the sighting
and did what they could to try to either
calm people down or to confuse them
or to you know to they do psyops that's
what they do oh you didn't see that it
was something else
they're deflating the gas light on like
crazy
yeah it's called it it's uh you know a
standard part of
psychological warfare operations it's
just a gaslight
well like i said i am reserving judgment
i don't know if it was extraterrestrial
or not i didn't see it
um you know but obviously the people
that first started seeing the [ __ ]
you know earlier in the evening like at
7 30. obviously they saw something that
was weird enough
that they reported it and because it was
people that didn't know each other like
all along this
like big distant line or whatever so
it's not like it was just one dude out
in the middle of nowhere that said oh i
saw
a ufo it wasn't like that i'm very
practical man
okay i've had a lot of experience in the
field
seen a lot of [ __ ] fighter aircraft
seen a lot of [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] choppers ch-47s uh-ones uh-60
blackhawks little birds
seen special operations [ __ ] go down
look aircraft fly over civilian [ __ ]
locations all the time
even little balloons and chinese
lanterns go over [ __ ] civilian areas
all the time they don't call the cops on
it
something very strange it was enough to
alert the people
they called the cop called 911c in this
thing
and they just said it was [ __ ] huge a
huge
black v with a varying amounts of
[ __ ] lights
big lights on it and sometimes they said
they could see through the v it would
like be
wavering like it was clear which i got
some explanations for all that if it was
a civilian or
if it was a earth aircraft and got some
ideas what could be
what why something would be shaped like
that why would it be big
how could it be transparent i got
explanations for all that
but i don't think that's what it was i
don't think what it was i think it was
extraterrestrial
just saying i'm gonna say i like that
you wore your plissken shirt tonight
because there is a kurt russell
connector
russell crussell saw it
[Laughter]
this is part of the crust i was going to
say this case is part of the crystal
clear
officially russell saw it he might have
been
allegedly he might have been the first
civilian to report it
they're not and they're not sure if he
is but flying his airplane saw it from a
distance and reported the lights
yeah he didn't know what they were you
know what he just said i just saw some
red lights in this guy
they're not really sure but he might
have been the first person to report
them
so it's kind of like but he didn't come
out he didn't come out until later went
across several states
and uh no they buried it they buried
this now do i think the
military knows what it was no i don't
think they do they just tried to hide it
if they can't they don't know what it is
they can't control it they're going to
try to gaslight you
because you have to have the illusion of
control well they well yeah that and
they don't want like everybody freaking
out on them too
yeah the illusion of control is to
maintain the illusion yeah we got this
[ __ ] all
yeah don't worry about that we got it
handled yeah
i want to talk a little bit too later
about um
who would that woman that uh said that
the phoenix lights had visited her
two years before lynn kate her name is
kate yeah
yeah i've heard some of her stuff i
don't know how credible she is i'm
some of the stuff she says i don't i
don't know yeah i watched the
different sightings she's talking it is
yeah i watched the documentary that she
made
um i said when did it come out 2007 i
want to say
and uh it's on i'm pretty sure it's on
youtube for free
and it's just called like a skeptic's
[ __ ] man what the [ __ ] the call the
phoenix lights a skeptic figures out it
has like this really long subtitle
yeah and i watched it earlier today and
i was just i don't know man it's like
after a while it just seemed like my
eyes started to glaze over and it was
just kind of like
it was weird because it seemed like a
lot of the
a lot of the um documentary was taken up
with
her being like well
holly blaming hollywood for making
everyone afraid of aliens even though
they're friendly
and wanting to teach kids about friendly
aliens i don't know i just
i kind of spaced out after a little
while you know what i mean but i did i
did actually kind of watch most of it
until i got bored and wandered off but
you know what i mean um and i think that
we have
don't we have her book somewhere yeah we
have a book i think i bought it used
the thing is though is that linky ty
says she saw the thing weeks before
everybody else no a couple years ago a
couple years and it was something low
and small
and near the ground it she's tripping
she's true
and and i don't know if she ever really
saw the main event i think she's trying
to tie in that the stuff that she saw
was that same because it was the same
because he's in that same area
i don't i don't buy it i don't but this
is one event
of a big air craft went through the air
some people say it was several craft
it's just that they were kind of similar
uh but i don't know i'm just going to
stick to that with one craft
you know what i learned today today
about uh len cote though
it's kate right katai okay i couldn't
figure out from the
uh from the spelling but you know what i
learned today that i did not know
was that she played florence arizona
in raising arizona she was the woman
that was she was like the babies oh yeah
the triplets like mom
and i was like no [ __ ] way i didn't
know she was an actress i didn't
recognize her
so you know because flor if you've seen
raising arizona like the um
you know florence had like the the bun
up in her hair and [ __ ] like that so i
didn't
you know i wouldn't have thought that
was the same woman but uh yeah
this that was something i learned today
so i was like huh well okay
all right so you want to talk about like
a timeline of
[ __ ] you just kind of bust because i
know you know probably way more about
the case than i do it's
in this case because you've watched a
lot of [ __ ] about this but people are
mentioning well you know it was
the flare the flare videos okay that was
bee's nest was talking about the flares
we could you can agree that that's a
flare
or something like flares falling behind
them damn mountain chains in that famous
video
whenever they show talk about the
phoenix lights they show that same
[ __ ] video
and that video has been debunked over
and over again
but there's another video of the phoenix
lights of the real craft from a distance
five lights in a v and it's real grainy
and real low quality so don't show it
much
and you can hear the people commenting
on it like look at that thing it's huge
you know and and it's got the little
date and the time you know they had the
old vhs players had a little date in the
time going
and it the resolution isn't good enough
to pick it up and it's miles away
uh but you can see the five lights and
it's in a perfect v
one in the front two and four four
behind it
so that's the phoenix lights now some
people give a differing number
and also the angle a little bit
different which that could be
that they're seeing it from different
attack angles at different angles of
attack
uh it could be that there's a
possibility that the ship
morphed or that it changed shape
that it may not been a real solid
physical
thing it might have been something you
know nanotechnology or something
something real sophisticated something
that could change shape
bizarre perhaps so and they said that it
got to where you could see through it
in certain at certain times maybe that
was its cloaking technology i think it's
a cloaking device
but you couldn't see through the lights
the lights were still illuminated but
but the
craft became clear and you could see
through it like waving like a heat wave
coming off the top of a but there's a an
earthly explanation for that there's a
technology that can do that
but go ahead i'm always going to say
though it's like if if it actually was
aliens
i wish that the aliens would either just
blow us up
or just help us out just like announce
yourselves
quit [ __ ] around no quit teasing us
no they don't care about us
you know what i mean i'm just saying
that you you
okay this is something that's very very
it's very common
for people to think that the aliens are
here to see us if they're here
which i believe they do i don't think
they give a [ __ ] about us no i'm sure
they probably no
they don't even recognize us as they
don't even see us as any different
they don't see us any different really
as any of the other animals here
yeah it's like oh it's like an ant hill
yeah i don't think they even recognize
what we're doing as a
as technology per se it's gonna if they
can get across that gulf of space
they're intelligent computers
they're not biological they're like
something out of 2001 a space odyssey
they're just monitoring the planet
because we're in their territory this is
their country
it's not our planet it's theirs and uh
they're just
we're interesting because things like
this planets like these are might be a
little bit odd
and we're making computers so they're
watching that
they wouldn't be interested in us they'd
be interested in those computers that
we're making
like i said i always kind of thought of
it as maybe we're just like tenants
and they're like the landlord and
they're kind of checking to make sure
that we don't [ __ ] anything up we're in
the hood
and that's the cops rolling through the
hood just make sure everything's okay
that's all it is um
[Laughter]
i think they're only [ __ ] they would
only be interested in our computer
technology they're waiting for some of
our computers to become sentient that's
what it is so they can talk to them so
they're gonna talk to the computer
yeah because they're going to see the
camera they're going to
they're going to see the computer as a
life form not us yeah
yeah i could see that so there wait no
the one of our kind is going to be born
here
soon we'll keep checking back every 10
years it's going to be like that
yeah by our you know they're gonna reach
[ __ ] critical mass and they're gonna
have
in computers that can that that will
become sentient maybe 20 30 years keep
checking back it's gonna be [ __ ] like
that
yeah it's like they're just you know
they still got to the good show yet
they're still like
meat sacks i don't like that well
they're going to be looking at us like
uh
part of the biological process that
gives birth to the intelligent computers
in the way that you see bacteria as
[ __ ] making
yogurt grow yeah making honey
yeah right they're waiting for the honey
or the yogurt they don't give a [ __ ]
about the bees
they don't give a [ __ ] about the bees or
the or or or the bacteria in the yogurt
you know they're just waiting for the
yogurt
i knew i liked these aliens for
something all right so
we're going to talk about the timeline
of what happened
so apparently now i don't know if this
was the if this was kurt russell's
sighting or not
no one wants to confirm that mango said
in the uk it was pretty much confirmed
that kurt russell said that he was the
first one that saw it yeah i don't know
but it's like he's
a legend no i think that's no he he um
if i remember correctly
he had he gave an interview that yeah he
did but i'm just saying that i don't
know if somebody had reported it prior
to him
reporting it he talked about it on a
talk show i heard him yeah
yeah i saw part of that yeah um so the
first
report uh was 7 55 pm that's mountain
standard time
now this first person perhaps kurt
russell
um said they saw a v-shaped object
above henderson nevada now at the time
this witness said it was about the size
of a 747
and was making a sound but it sounded
like rushing wind
this person also reported that this
whatever it was
had six lights on its leading edge
so it was v-shaped but it had six lights
yeah like that
and it was going uh northwest to
southeast
that was the direction it was traveling
like i said this might have been the
kurt russell site i'm not really sure
but that's the first one that they have
documented
what state was this in this was in
nevada okay so
but yeah so it was up north still yeah
yeah i mean it's called the phoenix
lights because a lot of people there
reported it but they actually saw it
over
several states and part of mexico too i
think yeah if you see where the
sightings were it
whatever it was it flew right across the
desert and it made it to all the major
cities
so it was like it was on a parade man it
was it was there to be seen
look at me look at me look at me
weird that is very weird and it would be
very hard to coordinate that across
several states
with thousands of people calling into
[ __ ] 9-1-1 well yeah there was just a
bunch of random people calling them they
didn't know each other
it was it was there was something there
was something there that was unusual
enough that caused all those people
to phone you know what i mean like i
said i'm not saying it was aliens i'm
just saying that it was something that
was
strange obviously so
uh the next one the next person to
report a sighting
was um a dude who was a former police
officer i'm not sure if anyone knows
what his name is he's unidentified
he was from paulden arizona and he had
left his house about 8
15 p.m mountain standard time he was
driving north and saw a bunch of
kind of red orange lights in the sky he
said that he saw
four lights together and then one light
behind them
that's what he saw yeah now this is
really weird i saw this on the wikipedia
page and i'm not sure
that i can picture what they're talking
about
but apparently he said that each
individual lights of the formation
because like i said he only saw five
apparently
he said each individual light consisted
of
two separate point sources of orange
light so i'm guessing he meant that like
one was round like that but there were
like two
no what he's saying is he's saying that
if you it looked like a light
but if you zoomed in on it with
binoculars or whatever it was
two little lights right next to each
other that's that's what they're saying
but it but he's
it's been described that they were kind
of like in a reflective dish looking
thing
yeah cause a lot of people describe them
as like canisters they were like a cat
yeah like a lot of people described
how you have a light bulb up inside of a
damn
ceiling in a restaurant yeah it's like
that
okay and there was two little tiny like
yeah cause i heard that description
and i'm like i'm not really sure i can
like picture some people described it
also as
it was it was they were round and it
looked kind of like uh like a swirling
kind of orange glowing plasma
but it's far away the eyes can play
tricks
you know what i mean yeah i mean i see
all kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah
like you know what i mean i think it was
just a um
like a a circular
bowl or disc shaped kind of socket like
an upside down swimming pool
with a couple of lights that's what i
was picturing and once the lights shine
it illuminates the swimming pool it's
like that
so the light looked big but it's
actually more like a reflective surface
and there's
a couple little bulbs a couple little
ones in there and they're lighting it up
that's what they're talking about
because when you said you know the thing
about the wavering and people said about
the canisters that's what i was
picturing i was picturing like a
swimming pool
like a light in a swimming pool that's
what i was yeah so i guess i was right
about that yeah
now is it a light or is it a propulsion
system
nobody knows yeah see like i said
just because it looks like a damn upside
down swimming pool with a fill
you know orange with a couple of light
bulbs in the bottom of it doesn't mean
that's what it is
yeah if it's some kind of advanced
technology
you will not be able to understand it by
looking at it there's more to what
you're seeing
well yeah i mean our brains if it was so
advanced that
we couldn't really fathom it or we
didn't really know like
understand what we were looking at then
your mind's going to go to the nearest
thing to it right
yeah um the thing about it though i was
uh what i was going to say was that
um did i mention that this was march of
1997 march of 1997. that's not happening
i'm not really sure i said what
month and what month it was what's you
what's weird is that
those large round swimming pools of
light
on the bottom of the craft there's there
are
several of these black triangle style
sightings and uh you know in other time
other places and other
you know other witnesses they kind of
report that
lights on the bottom of it kind of big
but dim
yeah sometimes they'll cast beams
out of the box yeah that's that's a
common that's another one it doesn't go
all the way to the ground
just to you know be a couple hundred
feet of like a beam through
through the dam you know humidity in the
air you can see it
just strange yeah well it's strange how
many people have seen these
i mean because like i said we did a show
a long time ago about uh
that illinois ufo sighting that was also
kind of like a black triangle this one
this one most people described it as
like a v or a boomerang
type shape but it was like really really
really big also the belgian sightings in
yupon
yeah in france the cops the zhonda marie
saw them
yeah and you know i i would uh believe
them
the whole bunches of them the cops were
chasing it the french cops
and they were seeing these [ __ ]
triangles they were smaller than this
though
yeah they were the craft was smaller
this this craft ended up being described
as
at least a mile wingtip from wingtip
yeah
this was a big thing that people saw
apparently it's huge
somebody asked earlier if we had done a
show about the rendelsham
uh that we did we did it was a while
back i think it was one of our christmas
specials
because it was something that happened
at christmas time so i think i did a
christmas ufo show and i think reynolds
i wouldn't give
reynoldshim too much credit outside of
what
what uh holt said was it colonel holt
i think carl holtz frank was yeah there
was a couple guys that are kind of iffy
and then the other ones about the damn
alien souls coming out of pyramid and
[ __ ] no i wouldn't believe that
and somebody asked if we had talked
about travis walton too i don't think we
did a show about travis walton but we
talked about him when we talked about
didn't we do a we might have done a
movie retrospective about that movie
that was about him
okay because i do kind of feel like
maybe we did talk that was a weird case
yeah i don't know if there's anything to
it yeah that was that dude he wouldn't
didn't he like disappear for a couple
days yeah
we should do like some alien abduction
like people that were gone like missing
time and stuff that'd be fun because you
could probably find a lot of
the thing with the renaissance is that i
i know that
well if you if you actually look at the
case and just strip it down to the
[ __ ]
what you know really happened not what
set what was said
but just the main part of the case it
boils down to lights in the sky there
were some radar returns
this other stuff about seeing the craft
and touching the crappiness
there's no that probably didn't happen
because only one guy says that
the other guy says well i didn't see
that yeah so
yeah this gets [ __ ] sketchy then
somewhere else
then another guy claimed well on another
on the other side of the base they had
everybody with
cameras and the aliens made a [ __ ]
landing just like out of close
encounters and alien souls came out of a
pyramid
i could see the faces in them and then
they debrief me whatever they don't know
what that means
they always say debrief okay they don't
know what that [ __ ] means okay
and then they tortured me and drugged me
and [ __ ] made that made me not
remember
and now get the [ __ ] out i mean the
thing about it i kind of feel like thank
you mango
travis walton is a can of worms yeah um
tb drinker said you did do a show on him
i knew i knew we had like talked about
it to some extent whether we talked
about the movie like fire in the sky i
couldn't remember
or if we did a show about them because
we've done so many shows i can't
remember what we've done and what we
have it
but um with randall shim just stick with
what carl holtz said
i just kind of feel like if you're gonna
do like a ufo story just
make keep it believable man it's like
just the second you go to zoe they
probed my anus and this and
the other thing um you know then your
credibility just starts going down and
down and down and down and down
just you know it's it should be creepy
enough that you saw some like scary [ __ ]
in the sky and then like you
and then you woke up three hours later
that's all just don't elaborate
holt said there was lights in the sky
later on it beamed something down in a
distance he saw something winking and
then later on which might have been the
lighthouse
but then later on they saw something
that looked like a damn fireball going
across the field but
look like molten metal dripping off of
it then it vanished
you know hard to say what that was i
mean
who knows and i mean the thing about it
too is that you know i'm not [ __ ] on
anyone's like
you know perceptions or credibility they
were excited but
yeah and the thing is that sometimes
like people's brains are imperfect
sometimes you
see [ __ ] you know that's all that's all
it is
um so yeah so this guy that saw these
lights in the sky like i said he had he
saw fi
he saw five of them and he actually saw
them for long enough that he had time to
turn around in his car
go back home get his binoculars and then
he watched them for like a little while
and then like they disappeared over the
horizon like going to the south
now about two minutes after that
um a bunch of callers from the prescott
valley area
um started calling in and reporting it
and
these callers i don't know how many of
them there were but they said
that whatever this object was it was
solid because they said they saw the
lights but they also saw that like a
bunch of the stars
you know the sky was like blocked out
like behind it
um so they started to report that it was
like one big massive
object right so this is like a couple
this is about 8 17 p.m
now the next uh named people
that apparently called in were devin
lawrence and his aunt jamie
and they're standing outside of the
house on the porch
and this is in prescott valley just like
most of the callers
just now were and they saw um
a whole bunch of lights they said the
lights looked
triangular all of them were red
except for the one at the like the apex
of the triangle which was definitely
white
now they said that they watched this for
about three minutes with binoculars
and then this whatever it was went
directly over them
banked to the right and then disappeared
to the southeast they said that they
didn't know exactly what the altitude
was
but they said it was pretty low because
you know they could see it pretty
clearly
and it didn't make any sound at all
that's what they said
now other reports came in from the same
area
and these people reported um
five yellow white lights in a v
formation
moving slowly from the northwest
somebody in the comments asked if
anybody saw it moving or
you know if they were just hanging there
not moving no they're moving most people
saw that they were moving
i never participed it just kept
gliding very slowly everybody said it
was very
serene and beautiful it was going over
the neighborhoods
sometimes very low and they got a one
really good witness he's dead now he's a
little
he was a little chubby dude and he would
fight you over [ __ ] what it was
because
he was convinced that he remembered it
so well
he said wingtip to wingtip it was at
least a mile and it flew right over his
house and the whole neighborhood
and then it went towards the mountains
and went
right in between a damn
valley between the mountains and the
wing tips
just barely missed the the mountain it
went right as low as it could
through a mountain you know i mean
through a draw in the mountain and then
kept on going
and it just was five lights one and four
and his son was with him and his wife
and the son said yeah you could see
through it you could see it
but it looked like waving water you
could see through it he said look
he said look like you know when you're
looking to heat waves on the road in
mississippi we call
monkey waves yeah monkey waves
monkeying with your vision okay monkey
monkey
and monkey look like monkey waves with
lights with the five lights in there
um but it was black too it was black and
then it turned evidently it turned into
monkey waves
like you liked it like it turned the
[ __ ] cloaking device on yeah
yeah man this thing's on the fritz again
yeah yeah
the klingons are in there trying to
[ __ ] turn the [ __ ] trying to fix it
but what's weird is you turn the
cloaking device off and you go invisible
but you still see the lights
which is a out of focus yeah that well
it seems it seems counterproductive
if you're going to have cloaking
technology you need to cloak the whole
[ __ ] [ __ ]
well that's just us that's just us
interpreting what we're seeing yeah
let's say it's
let's say it's extraterrestrial maybe
from
certain angles you see it for what it is
it's black
but when it gets overhead it looks clear
because
maybe the anti-gravity repulsion starts
bending the light waves underneath it so
it looks like
right but it's an accidental effect it's
not a cloak it's just because it's
it's got some kind of a suspension field
or something
which makes it look distorted which
that's
one thing that i thought of oh okay i'm
talking about yeah in other words it's
like it's a repulsor technology
from some certain angles it looks
alright but directly underneath it
it gets distorted you know that makes
more sense than cloaking technology that
doesn't cloak the bright light
exactly that's what i was now that's my
extraterrestrial explanation
there's another explanation if it was
terrestrial but i don't know
maybe okay i'll talk about it now it
doesn't really matter does it there's a
it was a long time ago
all right it's in the 90s so if it was
if it was a a man-made aircraft it would
have been
[ __ ] cutting-edge technology but it
doesn't have to be as cutting as you
think it is because i explained later
what
possibly could have been maybe the skin
of the aircraft was a lcd
screen like you're telling like a modern
television yeah see i like that
uh that theory and then the other side
of the [ __ ]
the top side of the craft was a network
of small cameras
all right nowadays those little tiny
cameras are right in every device that
you have
all right and what it's doing is it's
taking a picture of the sky
above it and try to replicate the star
pattern underneath it so when you look
up you see a live action
moving camouflage
star pattern but it's imperfect it looks
like it's waving
because the technology's not that good
yeah they said you could see the
stars through it but they were kind of
waving you know
wavy they were they're monkey waves you
know well it might have been that the
technology wasn't that good yeah
and maybe that's why i mean maybe that's
why somebody built that like the
military built it or whoever and then
they're like let's fly this over the
[ __ ] city and see if anybody can see
it
well i got a lot of features i got a lot
i got a lot of theories
back to the drawing board i got a lot of
theories of why you might do that
i'll talk about them now or i could talk
about them later
but maybe we should talk about them
later should we talk more about the case
uh which that way i could give maybe an
explanation for it
but it could possibly be that you're
looking at human
camouflage technology primitive lcd
tele screens with very primitive micro
cameras in the top of it
yeah because this was 97 97 they still
had some [ __ ] like that
but not as good as nowadays the stuff
that's in your cell phones
would do that today okay you could do
that
very easily today yeah back in the 90s
it would be a lot harder
but they had the they had the technology
but it cost a lot of money
and it would all been custom this
wouldn't have been something that was
meant
mass produced this would have been a
custom built craft
for a purpose and i know what the
purpose could possibly
be possibly
but maybe i'll talk about that later
let's talk about it now
it doesn't matter actually it doesn't
really matter okay
there was a time in the united states it
was focused on something called the sdi
program which is strategic defense
initiative
we were looking into technicians in the
80s all right which one
if this thing appearing in the late 90s
if it appeared in the late 90s it would
it would take at least a decade to get
that [ __ ] flying
so it would have been a product of the
eight of the late 80s at least
okay sdi was all about
shooting down incoming missiles
okay incoming soviet icbms
at this time there is no soviet union
it's already collapsed but you might
still have a lot of that technology
you're still working on it
one of the problems with shooting down
an incoming icbms
just to detect the launch
and then track the incoming trajectory
of these dab missiles
if you had a radar system radar systems
are fixed
and they can't see over the horizon but
if you could put a radar way up at high
altitude and keep it on station for
years without that thing ever having to
land
okay you'd have an advantage you'd be
able to see over the horizon
to track an incoming icbm okay
so what you do is you take a solid
solid body zeppelin all right and put it
very it has to be huge because you need
a big [ __ ] radar
array in it okay so it has to be big
and it's a zeppelin so you're gonna
shape it
in a stealth shape which back in those
days would have been a triangle or a v
all right just like the stealth bomber
right just like the stella bomber
and it's and zeppelins are very high
lift so you could lift a very
heavy [ __ ] radar antenna
all right and if you're gonna have that
thing up there
you might as well have that thing up
there for a long long time okay
so you can't power it through jets that
[ __ ] has got to be nuclear
so you take the nuclear reactor out of a
[ __ ] submarine
and you use that to drive [ __ ] big
electric coils
so you can have all the power you ever
need to run all your [ __ ] radar
assemblies
your radar array all your graphics and
all your psychological camouflage
and everything right and you can have
that thing up there for years because
maybe no crew maybe wireless
communication
because it wouldn't need a crew it's not
a fighter plane
you know what i mean yeah it doesn't
need a crew
it's not going to be what's it what's
that thank you victor i almost forgot
again
start over
[Laughter]
he almost forgot again what time it was
yeah yeah we started we're doing friday
night yeah
so there's a possibility what this could
think could be is a [ __ ] ver is a
very stealthy
radar array all right that's unmanned
now you'd be like well why are they why
are they flying it over a [ __ ]
arizona and utah letting everybody look
at this thing
well let's think about this for a while
what kind of camouflages are there well
one kind of camouflage you make
something invisible
another kind of camouflage is to kind of
break up its [ __ ] pattern
so when it's on the background of a
bunch of leaves you can't really
make out shape and you don't notice it
because it's the wrong color
but there's another kind of camouflage
it's called a camouflage called dazzle
all right and dazzle's when you see
something just overwhelms you
okay so you're hiding it in plain sight
so you see this thing's got his lights
on it's a [ __ ] amazing
hugo this is a [ __ ] alien spacecraft
i'm going to report this [ __ ] alien
spacecraft
you get on the phone i'm seeing a ufo
alien spacecraft they man get the [ __ ]
out of here
and they hang up on you hello ufo
reporting people
so you reported it and what happened it
wasn't believed
that's what happened right here
thousands of people reported this thing
that's not believed
so that's successful camouflage
well and people are still talking about
it
yeah so you're being seen but not
understood
it's another form of camouflage yeah see
i
like that i like it yeah i like that so
that's might be what we're talking about
here
maybe but i don't think so i think it's
extraterrestrial
okay yeah you think so yeah okay so
all right so we're still over prescott
at this point so like i said people are
seeing kind of yellow white lights in a
v
formation um basically what the later
report said that there was three lights
like one two
three like that like in a little
triangle and then the two of them were
like farther back like along the
legs of the v um yeah so they were kind
of going
and other people were reporting like you
know a lot of the sky was blacked out
so the next named people uh are tim and
bobby
lay and they were also in prescott
valley
now they saw this a similar thing about
65 miles away from them
they said that they saw when they first
looked up in the sky they said they saw
five lights that were separate
but they were like in an arc shape they
described it as
as if the lights were on top of a
balloon so like you know
a parabola i guess um but then it looked
like the lights were moving toward them
they said they watched them for at least
10 minutes
and as the lights got closer they
started taking the shape of an upside
down
v now they said
that when the lights got to be only a
couple miles away from them
then it started looking like what
someone described as a 60 degree
carpenter square
um with five lights set into it one on
the front and two on each side
um now that's the most common
description of it yeah
a carpenter's square with five lights
some people say seven
but five i think most people agree
things i think it was most commonly five
um and a lot of people said that there
were three in the front and then two a
little farther back
yeah um you know and but some people
said it was like even but you know it's
like some people were saying
like different yeah somebody said this
another one said there was the five
lights but behind it was a sixth light
trailer behind it
and it broke away from it and did some
stuff and then came back
and redocked and then went out but
yeah who knows and this is what this i
think you mentioned this earlier but
um this is around the time that people
started reporting that
the craft was actually really low only
about 150 feet above them
and it was kind of going down the street
yeah like a residential street
silently yeah and they said there was no
noise and it was going like really slow
and a lot of people saw it
yeah um so at this point it kind of went
over their heads
and went uh through the peaks of the
mountain range like you mentioned
earlier
so when i went over there went over that
dude's neighborhood like i was telling
you about
yeah he said it was beautiful there's a
lot of interviews with that guy
yeah and he just said it was a
life-changing event since he's through
he he just might drop and walked away
yep there's aliens yeah i'm out and
whenever they come at him saying well
could that have been a an
uh like a a secret weapon he he would
get furious
no he says no [ __ ] way since that was
a
an extraterrestrial craft is that it was
so silent and so
beautiful and so serene and it was just
extremely grandiose
and it was just says no that they said
no in no way was that man-made
it just a lot of people did say that
yeah you know
yeah that a lot of people have the same
uh reaction yeah
now it was like seeing god damn
something like that yeah that's just
that it was just this perfect
shape it was just perfect and it was
totally silent
and it was just stunning
i've seen some bad ass [ __ ] but i always
knew what it was yeah
yeah well i mean if you saw something
like this and you
i mean that was just completely out of
your realm of understanding
he said imagine a shopping mall going
over your head
huh yeah okay
that's up he said he said once one side
of the wingtip was way over there and
he's
standing out in front of his house the
other one was way over there at the end
of the thing he said it was like that
it was gigantic one thing that they did
talk about a lot on that
kind of cheesy documentary i watched
earlier yeah um
was that they made a great deal about
how
most of the witnesses were not scared of
the thing
even though they were like freaked out
like holy [ __ ] what is that thing
but they didn't think that it was like
menacing which is really weird because
you would think
that i mean you would think that
you know like an independence day like
that scene with like the [ __ ]
you know massive [ __ ] spaceship like
coming over the thing and like everybody
freaking like you would freak out you
would think
but a lot of people didn't freak out
even though they said it was like
enormous and
they said that it was very serene and
that it was uh
calming and that it was just like you
were just absolutely just blown away
and that it was definitely trying to be
seen that this was like a parade
it was letting you see it which that's
that i know the feeling yeah you know
what i mean but he said it was
letting you see it that's why it was
that's what it was doing
look at me yeah
that's pretty that's a statement it is
you know what i mean that's why i'm
thinking i don't think it was a secret
craft
because they wouldn't fly it that way
well apparently i mean the people in
this one neighborhood this it was like
it's only like 150 feet off the ground
that's not very high at all
you know no it didn't have it didn't
have the
characteristics and the behavior of of
of a piloted craft that was a secret
craft and a secret radar platform or
anything
yeah nah the air force
is even the air force is very
conservative
you know you know what i mean they would
be afraid of lawsuits
that's what that's the way they are yeah
you know what i mean they just
now they keep that thing out of sight if
they had it because it's you know out of
sight out of mind
they don't want to test the camouflage
ability they wouldn't they wouldn't even
bother
they just wouldn't this they're very the
air force and look
i'm gonna start [ __ ] with air force
people but
[Laughter]
air force has no culture they're very
[ __ ] boring
they don't have much of a personality
they're glorified bus drivers
that's what that's what most of them are
fighting yeah it's kind of funny
they don't have a culture of their own
or a personality of their own it's very
in in a certain way you know what i'm
talking about
they're not ballsy they don't do that
kind of [ __ ] they would get in trouble
very very by the book very bland
you know now an army airborne unit
oh [ __ ] no they're gonna [ __ ] up man
you're gonna cut up
if you have a bunch of teenage [ __ ]
guys in their early twenties their human
weapons systems basically no they're
gonna [ __ ] up
they're gonna do all kinds of wild ass
[ __ ] they are
because they don't what are you gonna do
you're punishing them they live in
punishment you can't punish them
let's take the experimental aircraft
yeah everyone will think it's a ufo it
would be
serious yeah look at this [ __ ]
come on back now [ __ ] you sir i ain't
mama
yeah the army infantry would do that
not the air force not the air force
they're like
[ __ ] what do you mean come back i only
got 90 days left before i ets
nothing you can do to me lock me up in
the stockade [ __ ] i'll just sit around
sleep and eat
you can't do anything to them you can't
punish them
yeah but you can punish pilots
you know you can take things away from
them you know you can't really take
anything from the infantry they don't
already don't have anything
you know what i mean they live it up in
the barracks it's a prison like
conditions
yeah we got nothing to lose got like
trying to get out of here and have a
good time
yeah several people have pointed out
that the navy called the air force the
chair force
yeah yeah i have heard that before yeah
i respect the air force for what it is
it's a lot of air power
but as a military unit it doesn't have
much of a culture
all right it broke off from the army it
used to be the army air corps and then
it just became more and more [ __ ]
conservative and
boring and very pampered and hotel
living [ __ ] and living up in a
goddamn hotel
hotel with a [ __ ] yeah the hotel
living
with like a [ __ ] 70 female cadre and
[ __ ] you know what i mean so they're
just surrounded by women that why are
they even wearing uniforms they might as
well just be civilians a lot of them
you know i came from the old army it was
like prison
you know dude guess what dude i saw a
woman
you saw it right she looked good
[ __ ] no [ __ ] was ugly still [ __ ] you
though
yeah who was it i don't know you know
your mom
[Laughter]
victor says the army videos on pornhub
are better than the air force ones
yeah i'm gonna be talking about army
women man
[ __ ] [ __ ] back in our day at least
army went over to
most when i was in army women were
hookers basically
they were they were hookers oh
man yeah you were talking well how are
they going to turn down that kind of
money
they're outnumbered like a hundred 200
to one and they're not much to look at
and there's all these looking good
looking [ __ ] guys and [ __ ] that are
[ __ ] young
and they they're gonna start charging
for it now they would get in trouble for
it too
but but like you said army people don't
care about that well they throw them out
so but there was a constant rotation of
cid which is our version of the fbi and
the army
their main [ __ ] job was to figure out
which one of these women are selling
how many hookers are in the army that's
really what they did mostly
how many hookers are in the army how
many how many how many hookers are in
the army and how many
and how many drug dealers in the army
that's all they did that's all they're
worried about
yeah funny yeah so all they did is root
out
hookers and drugs
hookers and drugs everyone's fine yeah
i'm not i'm i'm not talking [ __ ] about
the army i'm an army
i'm gonna talk [ __ ] because y'all
deserve it you know
you know what you are you know what you
are [ __ ]
you can't lie to me and you can [ __ ]
block the video you know
he said something bad about [ __ ] come
[ __ ] please
i grew up in that [ __ ] man i know what
it is
the drink that i had today where did
your drink go i drank it oh
well yeah but usually the glasses oh the
glass is still there usually
there's no glass there all right yeah
the the drink he made today he went to
the liquor store
and bought he got some more um coconut
vodka i think but he also got some of
that cake vodka
so he mixed a drink and it was cake
vodka
pineapple juice and a little bit of
grenadine and it tastes exactly like a
pineapple upside down cake
cake it's fantastic the thing he had was
not good though i don't know what that
was
it was it was cake too but it was mixed
with something else and it was kind of
weird tasting
so uh so yeah so all of these people
apparently saw this
big thing um between 8 30 and 8 45
p.m mountain standard time now
this guy here here's another guy that uh
that kind of came forward and said what
his name was
so the at this point like i said this
wasn't even over phoenix
yet but at this point it comes over
phoenix
and well hi pookie
[Laughter]
what should you see your little face
like pop up on the side of the chair
she's like i thought daddy was in this
chair where did he go but yeah so
uh so this triangular formation of
lights comes over the phoenix
area so there's this dude named bill
greener griner i don't know how to
pronounce that
he is a truck driver he's driving a
cement truck
and he's kind of driving down a mountain
road in phoenix
and he saw the lights
and he is quoted as saying i'll never be
the same
before this if anybody had told me they
saw a ufo i would have said yeah and i
believe in the tooth fairy
now i've got a whole new view and i may
be just a dumb truck driver
but i've seen something that don't
belong here so
that guy saw that um he said
that the lights were there for like
two hours like while he was driving
around so it wasn't just kind of like oh
i saw him for a second and then it went
away
like apparently these lights were kind
of hanging out they were moving but they
were like hanging out for a couple hours
um just a little bit after that there
was
another report that came in from a dude
who
he was driving to los angeles and he
stopped in
kingman and he stopped at a pay phone
and he said i saw this really really big
cluster of stars that's what he called
it uh moving slowly in the northern sky
so like i said you're getting all this
all these random people
along this route that this whatever it
is is taking
and they're kind of calling in uh you
know
now interestingly um
so those were kind of like the main ones
from the first
uh sighting because like i said we we
kind of
implied it earlier but there were
actually two sightings and the ones you
see the videos of are not necessarily
the ones that we're talking about here
now interestingly
many years later more than 10 years
later in 2008
um some phoenix residents reported
seeing lights
again over the city
and uh thank you i was telling them the
drink that you made that was like really
really good
um and these lights just like before
like looked like they were changing
shape so i guess they were like started
out square and then they went to
triangular
now i guess that
what ended up happening with this one
was that they
like one witness said that they saw the
lights and then they saw like three
jets so like you know if you think like
out west in this area like arizona else
new mexico all that kind of stuff so
there's all kind of like air force bases
and [ __ ] like that out there so
there's always there's always kind of
planes and missions and [ __ ] like that
they're flying so it's always
that's why there's a lot of sightings
out there but
they called uh the nearest air force
base and of course they were like yeah
it wasn't us
whether that means that was uh them or
not i don't really know
but a few days after that
somebody came forward to the paper and
said i think that those lights
were my neighbor my neighbor was in his
backyard
tying flares to balloons like helium
balloons and then releasing them into
the sky
i don't know if he was doing that i mean
i can't think of any other reason he
would have been doing that other than
hey i'm going to pretend it's ufo um i
don't know if that's true or not but
like the neighbor did say
that he saw his neighbor doing that
so it could possibly be that it was just
this dude attaching flares to his
uh two balloons in his backyard
so now as i mentioned earlier most of
the
photos and video footage of the
quote-unquote phoenix lights
this was all of that stuff
is from the event
that happened like at 10 p.m now if
you'll note
most of the timeline that i was talking
about earlier
that [ __ ] started at like 7 30 and went
to like
from like 7 30 to like 8 45 p.m
that was when people were reporting
seeing you know five or six red orange
or yellow white lights in a triangular
formation we're reporting seeing this
really big craft and [ __ ] like that
now at around 10 o'clock p.m
mountain standard time um there was a
[ __ ] ton
of videos and photos and stuff like that
taken of other
lights in the sky but apparently this
was not the same
thing it was not the same phenomenon you
know what i'm saying
yeah so it so if you see because
as far as i know now i've seen some
stuff that said oh there's no video
of the original sighting or there's no
photos of the original sighting
however there were there was a rumor i
don't think i've ever
i think it's on youtube and somebody
cleaned it up or anything i don't know
if it's real or not
but apparently somebody did take kind of
a crappy
video of the original um
you know the original sighting but it's
really really far away and it doesn't
really look like much of anything even
though the video has apparently been
enhanced
you know what i'm saying but
yeah so the thing about it okay so so
nothing has been
like uh you know nothing was taken with
night vision
cameras nothing was taken with any
high-powered cameras or anything like
that they were all just like regular ass
cameras regular ass like [ __ ] video
camera [ __ ] like that
now apparently there was a dude named
richard curtis
and he supposedly had recorded this
really super detailed video
that supposedly allegedly showed
the outline of the craft but
perhaps conveniently this video is
lost so as i said the only other known
video of it is
like really really shitty looking and
it's basically just like a bunch of
lights
with a v in a v shape um
and that's the one that's on youtube i
guess it's still there like to this day
so you know the second event that
happened at 10 pm that's the one that
everybody got pictures of
i don't you know what i mean it's like i
don't know
if because when the first sightings
happened
like starting at 7 30 p.m or whatever it
was
um i don't think it wouldn't have been
reported on the news quick enough
for people to have been out like looking
at the sky i think a lot of people were
outside looking at the sky because
wasn't there like supposed to be like a
comet or um
that night or like a [ __ ] or a you
know sharp
what do you call it like a meteor shower
or something wasn't it supposed to be
like the
like a meteor shower that night well
yeah that's something you saw
no no no i'm saying but that's why a lot
of people were outside
that's why there were so many witnesses
i think that there was supposed to be
some kind of like cool like
astronomical kind of [ __ ] that night i
can't remember what it was but i think
there was like a meteor shower
so that's why so many people were
outside like looking up at the sky
you know what i'm saying yeah i've been
there and they're talking about me
[ __ ] being a politian and [ __ ] me
needing testosterone to replace my
strength and [ __ ]
why don't you talk about ufos i gotta go
to the bathroom
go ahead don't just sit there staring at
them
no i do what i want to do i'll talk to
when i want to do that
okay yeah of course
okay yeah
they tried to play this one off they
tried to play this one off and then they
went up there and they shot those
[ __ ] flares
to try to gaslight people that they
didn't you didn't see that
you saw these flares
air force was in on it somebody
somewhere
had them do that
that right there to me is a giveaway now
there was a training
operation going on it was eight tens
they were [ __ ] doing groud attack
training
and the a-10s were they were launching
off some flares
uh countermeasures [ __ ] like that
uh what a counter measure is if somebody
shoots a uh
heat seeking missile at you uh you can
fire off a counter measure
and it's a cluster of these damn flares
they're real hot
it's not the same kind of parachute
flare it's it's just the flare that
falls out
hot sparks it looks like fireworks
and it's to confuse that heat-seeking
missile hopefully it'll lock onto that
instead of your
jet exhaust i don't know how you know
i don't know how good they are they
probably work if they didn't work then
they wouldn't use them
probably has something to do with the
down wavelength
the wavelength of light or heat coming
out out of the dam
flare might be similar to what comes out
of the back of the jet engine so it
confuses some missiles imagine a good
missile probably didn't
confuse them at all but i don't know
i have a [ __ ] sneaking suspicion and
i suspected this even back in the day
when it happened
you know because when this [ __ ] happened
it spooked a lot of people
uh people in the media were trying to
play it off like it was funny
and when they were playing it off like
it was funny that actually made me feel
more uncomfortable because i having a
background be coming from you know
operations in north korea and stuff i
knew what propaganda was and
psychological
operations because they were being
light-hearted and trying to laugh it off
the government propaganda networks there
was something to it
there wasn't anything to it it never
would have even been mentioned well the
interesting thing about this though was
that the phoenix lights case
it was only reported locally
just in little bitty things until i
guess usa today picked it up
but that wasn't until like two or three
months later and then it went
national i remember when it happened
because like i said i was listening to
[ __ ] art bell
and um i heard rumors of it first
and then right after it happened art
bill had a show on it i was [ __ ]
blown away
yeah so he might have helped but like i
said it's kind of really didn't get a
lot of national press until usa today
picked it up and that was like in june
yeah so that was like march april major
that was like three or four months yeah
it built up
for a while but then like uh there was
there was a there was a propaganda
campaign to try to diffuse it and
gaslight it away that went along
that went on for months
so i kind of thought there was something
to it
well yeah like i said it's it's entirely
possible right
so like i said so the ones that you see
most often see videos of in
documentaries and stuff
this one it looks like more it's not
really triangular it's kind of like an
arc shape
and the lights kind of show up like one
by one and then they go out one by one
that says something interesting she says
interest oh no okay i'm sorry
she said she's interested to know if the
phoenix lights will be part of the
supposed ufo
the government report coming out in june
no it won't be
evidently the report in june is about
more tic tac ufo stuff with the with the
navy
that's what it's evidently going to be
according to marco rubio
he's seen it well i mean we'll see how
it goes they asked him they said well
what is it is it extraterrestrial
he was just like you tell me
i don't know i didn't see it that's just
what the report said yeah he's like that
you know
yeah he didn't want to get trapped he
was interested in
it little little little marco
martin that was funny when they dug up
the photo of
marco rubio [ __ ] shirtless with his
little bow tie on when he was doing the
[ __ ] stripper dance did you see that
um long time ago that was a long that's
when he was trying to run for president
[ __ ] they brought that up to try to
to try to knock him out of [ __ ] the
running of the president and i'm like
dude this is not [ __ ] 1981 that would
not knock a [ __ ] out of being
[ __ ] presidential candidate [ __ ]
that'll elevate it
chippendale it is chippendale's outfit i
vaguely remember that i don't know it's
like [ __ ] funny
i can't even write [ __ ] america it's
[ __ ] ridiculous our politicians are
[ __ ] ridiculous
this whole country is ridiculous to be
honest with you
[ __ ] crazy but yeah so so some people
have said that this second
you know the videos of this second one
um
you know oh maybe because the lights
kind of come
into existence and then go out of
existence maybe it's like running lights
or it's like some kind of
you know if whatever it's you know
running lights along a [ __ ]
spacecraft or whatever but like i said
the [ __ ] that you see
in the second videos that's not really
what people reported people didn't
report
a bunch of little lights like in kind of
an arc shape that were like disappearing
they reported five or six big like
canister type lights
in a v-shape yeah that was like two
different things
so i kind of feel like maybe what
happened
and you were saying this too is that
people saw some weird [ __ ] early in the
evening from
like i said 7 30 to 8 45 p.m
and then maybe who
like whoever you know has control of
these things we're like hey won't you
fly up there and like drop some flares
and we'll tell everybody that that's
what it was well evidently that's what
had happened
you couldn't confirm that well it's not
any nothing like this
is confirmed okay i mean they do know
okay they did
some planes did go out yeah and drop
flares they do know that that's
confirmed
um and that was like at around 10 p.m so
that's obviously what some people were
seeing
but the fact that that's what those
people were seeing that's not
necessarily what the people
earlier were seeing because that was
like several hours before they had
apparently gone out to drop these flares
yeah but you know what i mean it's i
don't know it's just
people that were in that area swear
that the thing flew over oh
what it was what was it eight o'clock
that it flew over daily craft
yeah like from from like 7 30 to like 8
45 yeah depending on where you several
people like reporting
on where you were and then around 10
some air force jets went up and dropped
flares and that's what they got
yeah because that didn't happen until
much later that was later
almost kind of like they were just kind
of they were trying to muddy the waters
to gaslight you
yeah i mean either that or it was just a
total coincidence that they were going
to do that anyway
and it's like they just happened to do
it on that night i don't really know i'm
gonna call [ __ ] on something
the famous video of the so-called venus
of phoenix lights with the
i guess their flares going behind the
mountains it looks like a big old
[ __ ] ark
i've been in [ __ ] on training
missions where we were doing [ __ ]
bunker assault
[ __ ] assaults on bunker complexes
down during aviation califax and south
korea
where we had a tens of support doing a
night [ __ ] attacks on [ __ ] bunker
complex systems
of course you know what i mean it's a
real bunker complex system but there's
nobody in there there's just [ __ ] man
targets and [ __ ] in there
and the a10s will come and drop flares
i've seen [ __ ] flare support from
a10s [ __ ]
since i was a kid you don't drop that
kind of flare
at that high altitude you drop those
things at low altitudes so they can cast
light on the ground
so whoever was dropping those [ __ ]
lights dropped them up that high on
purpose
that's odd yeah you know what i mean you
don't drop them up that high
you drop them low you're trying to
illuminate the ground
yeah i mean now that i'm thinking about
it it's like what's
really the point there's no point of
going
dropping flares up in the air you know
what i mean
so i'm already calling [ __ ] we want
to look at the clouds look at the lights
no no look at that light that's exactly
what that means look at that light
look at that light in reality they they
[ __ ] fly a couple hundred meters over
the [ __ ]
ground and drop some flares so the guys
on the ground fighting
can fight in the daylight really it'll
light up the whole [ __ ] ground like
daylight
they are very bright yeah and you can
see them from like 75 miles away
like not apocalypse now as the [ __ ]
as the [ __ ] flare
falls the shadows all change so there's
all these shadows swirling around you
from all the bushes in the trees it's
very eerie especially if there's more
than one in the air at once then you get
all these weird conflicting
shadows it's like a kaleidoscope and
it's weird it's like looking at the
surface of the moon it's either [ __ ]
brightest day or [ __ ] black as night
all the
shadows you know what i mean right there
in the same field of vision it's weird
yeah you know what i mean all these
[ __ ] black shadows [ __ ] swirling
around inside of a sea of white
it's bizarre i mean i'm pretty sure that
like
most people are don't question that at
least the second
sighting which happened you know around
10 p.m
is probably flares well that's that
famous video of the phoenix lights that
is flares falling behind the [ __ ]
mountain
i'm gonna tell you people
that that may be flares i don't see the
[ __ ] smoke trail coming up
but maybe it's because it's low
resolution video yeah maybe you just
couldn't see it from that far away maybe
if i was right if you were there you
could see it
but that's improper deployment of flares
you don't [ __ ] drop a flare that high
an illumination floor yeah say they must
have been doing it yeah they were doing
it
because they look at it because either
they knew what the [ __ ] was that people
had seen earlier and they wanted to like
cover it up or they didn't know what the
[ __ ] was earlier and they still wanted
to cover it up
that's what i think it was i think they
didn't know what it was and they were
trying to defuse the situation
to [ __ ] i think they didn't know what
it was i think they thought
it was probably extraterrestrial let's
go up there and draw some flares and
we'll tell them they saw that and it'll
[ __ ]
look over here afterwards you'll be like
no you didn't see them
and then there's somebody in the
intelligence agencies who are where
they're like i don't know what that was
i think the aliens are watching us they
might be watching us you know
there's some [ __ ] like that the thing
about it i kind of feel like
when you see a lot of these
documentaries because i watched one
another documentary called ufo hunters
and uh they were uh you know they were
kind of looking into this case as well
i feel like that's kind of the linchpin
of a lot of these
ufo advocate shows let's call them that
is one of the things they're trying to
debunk
is that the second sighting was flares
so they'll try to like
replicate it you know what i'm saying
yeah so a lot of shows will have a thing
where it's like we replicated didn't
look anything like the [ __ ] so it
must have been aliens but like i said
they're confusing the issue i think too
now
there's another dude and this dude um
they wrote about him on the wikipedia
page but also
he was in the um that would do that lynn
the lincoln documentary
this dude he's like all you know gung-ho
about ufos his name's uh
jim dill dilitoso dilitoso
so one thing that he did and this is
okay so this is something i love about a
lot of these people that
are and i'm like i said i'm not saying
the original sighting wasn't
extraterrestrials i don't know i didn't
see it
the second one was probably flares so
calm down but
this is one of my favorite things about
anybody that believes in these sort of
like paranormal kind of things
it's like they always kind of do this
thing that
to them seems scientific and i guess to
other people sounds scientific
but really if you think about it it's
really not what they think it is
you know what i'm saying this is kind of
like a prime example of that
so this dude said that
he took the video footage of the second
incident
which was like i said that would that
most people understand was flares
he wanted to prove that it wasn't
players so he took some of the photo
images and the video images and he took
them through
a program called image pro plus and he
tried to prove
by making a histogram of you know the
red green blue
you know spectrum like the light
spectrum yeah um he was trying to prove
that that wasn't flares by comparing
the rgb spectrum you know in the
histogram from that one
to ones of known flares but he was kind
of claiming
that just by essentially i guess like
eye dropping
you know the the color or whatever like
in the thing that he could determine
what
that light was made of uh and well yeah
and
the thing even the people that make the
program are like yeah our show can't do
that right
well well because the thing about it is
that one
when you take a photograph or a video of
something you are inherently changing
the you know the light the the histogram
you're changing like the light you know
uh
quality because yeah and and also
when you do that you are not getting
infrared you're not getting ultraviolet
you're not getting other things like
that that are going to
you know feed into what your you know
spectrum your spectral analysis is
spectroscopy spectroscopic because i
can't say that [ __ ] word
so yeah well no it's not even so much
that i've i've only had like one drink
so
i just can't really say that word but um
but so
he tried to make it look like
you know i did this and that like
scientific analysis
on these pictures and it's not you know
it's not the same as the light from a
flare
but as i said i don't think that
i just i don't think that you can get
that just from photos or
you know what i mean you're not getting
a a spectroscopic analysis
of just from a picture well he's talking
about he's talking about the video of
the [ __ ] the famous flair video
yeah yeah he's trying to prove that it
wasn't flares yeah because basically
he's trying to do yeah and it's like if
you think about it for five minutes it's
just like
cameras aren't the cameras aren't
sensitive enough and accurate enough to
give you what the exact spectrum was to
begin with anyway because
that's what i'm saying it's already one
thing removed from reality reality so
and there's all and cameras and stuff
only capture like a small portion of the
visible light spectrum
you know and you need like other you
need parts of the invisible spectrum to
get an actual like spectroscopic
analysis
of what that is right what the light is
comprised of and you can't do that
before thinking from an old vhs [ __ ]
video yeah this is 1997. it was cheap
[ __ ] even nowadays it wouldn't work
but like you know back then it really
wouldn't have worked because a lot of
the you know a lot of the photos and
videos of it are like really kind of
shitty quality i think it was flares
you can't see the smoke trail above the
flares but that might have been because
the resolution was so low that's all i'm
going to say
about that it looked like flares
improper deployment of flares
as a diversion to say no you saw flares
i don't know why you'd [ __ ] drop a
[ __ ] illumination flare that [ __ ]
high
yeah it was just to deceive people they
didn't know what it was something flew
over they're trying to calm people down
and then they would buy them time to do
an investigation i don't think they knew
what it was
i don't think they ever found out what
it was and they were saying too that
when they analyzed
you know like um you know the weather
conditions that night [ __ ] like that
and they said you know the way the wind
was blowing the way people reported the
second incident
um you know it looked pretty much like
somebody just dropped some [ __ ] out of a
plane like flares or something and that
was the way that the wind was going it
wasn't
another real suspicious thing about this
is that the craft
i'ma call it a craft it flew right over
a [ __ ] air force base and now the air
force base was not active at that time
no flights were going out of it
right over the air force base and they
denied see they did they said they
didn't see it
they denied knowing anything about it i
was talking about it
we didn't see that yeah
yeah you think that you know
maybe maybe it's radar resistant i don't
know but uh
everybody else could see it yeah you
would think the air force would know
what was going on in the sky wouldn't
you
i mean you would hope so yeah
that's the thing it's like when they
deny it it could mean that they know
exactly what it is but they don't want
you to know
yeah or it could mean that they have no
idea what it is and they don't want you
to know that they don't know
and then i also remember that one of the
the 911 dispatcher called the dam air
force
they called the air force um um
airport and asked them if they had
anything flying and no nothing flying so
they were aware
that people were seeing stuff yeah
they just didn't want to admit it yeah
so
like i said that could totally go either
way yeah it could be extraterrestrial or
it could be like some weird [ __ ] they
came up with
and they just don't want anybody to know
about it because it's like no one's
supposed to know about it
i got a feeling they didn't do anything
i got a feeling they didn't know what it
was
but yeah maybe yeah now interestingly
like i said so
so the second event um probably flares
um the first event still kind of
unexplained
although and this is actually the first
time that i learned this
apparently there's a reporter named
janet gonzalez
and she had seen videotape of the
original incident because like i said
there was actually kind of a shitty
video of that
and after analysis of that
um allegedly it might be
that the lights people saw the five or
six lights that people saw were actually
not
part of one craft but were five were
separate
yes now guys and hang gliders with
lights maybe well
no planes interestingly there is this
one guy
he's an amateur astronomer named mitch
stanley
and he was looking through his telescope
that night
like i said there was like some kind of
like i can't remember what it was but i
think it was like a meteor shower so
there were a lot of people like you know
watching this guy that night now he was
looking through his telescope that night
it was 43 times magnification
and he saw the original lights
apparently
um he reported later he saw the original
lights but he didn't think they were
unusual
like he told his mom at the time oh it's
planes that they were planes flying in
formation
yeah it could be that people were just
seeing them and
there's kind of a thing where if you see
a couple like a bunch of things like
grouped together like to kind of
group them into one big thing and
they're like so maybe people were just
like seeing it from farther away than
they
than they thought and so they just kind
of grouped it into one thing even though
it was five separate things i think he's
confused
i don't know i'm just saying that this
guy came forward and he was talking to
like a newspaper reporter and he said i
saw the [ __ ] through my telescope and it
was very clearly plain
reports came into 911 dispatchers
across several states in an organized
fashion
you couldn't so there there it would
have been planes flying together and
people would have had to abide
bought into it that it was one thing i
don't believe so
too many people saw it [ __ ] low and
said no it was like a carpenter's square
it was a triangle
like yeah you know it's like a carpenter
square
that's what i think it would probably
work i mean like i said the second
it seems like the second event is pretty
well five simon's in the [ __ ]
governor let's kind of talk about that a
little bit easter it says yeah
yeah but the thing about this you didn't
admit to it right away
fife simonton was the governor of
arizona at the time yeah
and uh or the governor yeah right yeah
around the state for a second i was like
got governor mayor confused
because you know that's that's how it
happens when you get old
you forget what words mean but there's a
very famous
video of him and he comes out doing a
press conference
and he's being super super serious and
he's like yeah we've been looking into
this like ufo [ __ ] or whatever and he's
like
we found the person responsible he says
did he say something like that we found
the person
responsible and then he had his [ __ ]
one of his uh
you know his aide or his secretary or
whatever comes out in an alien suit
yeah and all the reporters well all the
reporters kind of like laughed
but then it was just kind of like you
know so he was just like making a joke
about it
all the witnesses were [ __ ] pissed
well i can imagine
because it's like if you saw something i
don't know
if you saw something like that and then
suddenly everyone was just like making
fun of you
yeah that would be that'd be a bummer
yeah um i've never seen a ufo like i
don't so i don't know
but so yeah so a lot of people were
really mad that he wasn't taking it
seriously
and then the whole kicker of the [ __ ]
was that
you know that was not too long after the
original sighting right
but then like 10 years later he comes
forward and says yeah i saw that [ __ ]
yeah and he was like all taking it
seriously and [ __ ] like that then he
said he said he wanted to kind of like
he said that people weren't in
damn near panic you know people in that
area
were [ __ ] panicked and that he wanted
to kind of
lighten the lighten the mood and kind of
say look we don't know what it was
you know um he he didn't say it didn't
happen
he said we don't know what it was
basically well that's kind of like the
safest answer yeah
now later on he said that he saw it from
a distance
and that it was a [ __ ] big black
[ __ ] craft
like like a garbage square lights on it
and um guy preston what was some kind of
secret craft right you know and
which that right there [ __ ] you can
find the interview
where on youtube of him being
interviewed by this [ __ ] total
chucklehead
simonton's trying to tell him that no
this is a [ __ ]
extraterrestrial craft and the other guy
keeps pushing him into trying to say
that it was a
secret aircraft and he was just like uh
no no no no
no you know that was a [ __ ] alien
craft that's like
what yeah i mean i'm really trying to
say i have some of his quotes here he
says i'm a pilot
and i know just about every machine that
flies yeah it was bigger than anything
i've ever seen
yeah um it remains a great mystery other
people saw
responsible people i don't know why
people would ridicule it
um and then he says it was enormous and
inexplicable who knows where it came
from
a lot of people saw it and i saw it too
it was dramatic and it couldn't have
been flares because it was too
symmetrical
it had a geometric outline a constant
shape yeah and he said i can
definitively say this craft did not
resemble any man-made object that i've
ever seen
it was certainly not high oh [ __ ]
okay it says it reconnected soon did it
reconnect
yeah okay we're back all right okay i've
never had that happen before
weird that is very weird yeah um there
was also
a councilwoman frances barwood
and this was like she was she's been on
a lot of the um
the documentaries about this so
apparently she was one of the kind of
like
i don't remember if she saw it
personally or not but she really wanted
to
um kind of launch an investigation into
it because she was like taking it
seriously and stuff
and one of the things that
i don't know why this stuck out to me
but they said this in the documentary
they said when she got like real serious
about it
and she interviewed like 700 witnesses
who had seen it and all this other kind
of stuff
she said other people in her office or
whatever
started making jokes about it like they
had business cards
printed with her name on it
but there was like no phone number and
then underneath it said something like
just speak to the tin foil i'll hear you
or something and i was like
that's super mean but also that's pretty
funny i got to admit
that was actually i was like it's kind
of terrible but also kind of funny
because i mean that was a good one that
was a good one speaking of the tin foil
i'll hear you
i think that's what it said under on the
business card that they made for her
well because and like i said she's been
interviewed on a lot of the [ __ ]
and she i don't know if she actually
thinks it's extraterrestrials but she
just
wants to know what it is and she thinks
it's shitty that
um everyone's just trying to kind of say
that these people didn't say
didn't see what they said they saw right
and like i said it's just i don't know
it just confounds the issue because so
many people like conflate it with
oh it was flares but that wasn't what
the original people reported that
happened later
you know what i mean so and like i said
i don't
know you know i we've talked about this
before that's why we don't do a lot of
ufo shows
but do i believe that there are
that there is intelligent life elsewhere
in the universe yes
um it would be dumb to think that there
wasn't because the universe is [ __ ]
vast
so there's probably some more [ __ ] like
us out there somewhere
or much smarter than us hopefully um
do they come here that's a different
question
um and i'm not really sure
i'm not really sure it's like the most i
will give it it's like do they come here
and like kind of like drop in and be
like hey what are y'all up to or
whatever or
send a drone or something like that to
just check on us
um i can go that far i don't these
people that are like oh i got abducted
and probed and all that other kid yeah i
don't know
or i got impregnated by aliens yet no
you didn't um that's that's some other
issues that you have going on
um but it's just it's a complicated
thing because like i said
saying that there's intelligent life
elsewhere in the universe is a
completely different thing
than saying that they come here and [ __ ]
with us do i think they come here and
[ __ ] with us no
but have they kind of like cruised by
and like kind of looked out look down
there maybe
maybe there's been
in recent history recent human history
actually there's some stuff that goes
back to the 1800s over san francisco
that's kind of questionable it kind of
resembles this site
but the thing is is that newspapers in
the 1800s lied i mean they openly lied
about a lot of [ __ ] but there were some
weird reports over san francisco [ __ ]
a huge
dirigible huge craft the lights on it i
remember those
yeah and then it just went away you know
could be what we know now you know
they're [ __ ] finding all these
[ __ ] planetary surveys they're
putting up new
sensors and new equipment because it's
easy to get into [ __ ] orbit now
soon we'll know uh but we do know this
earth-like planets are pretty common
a lot more common than we thought uh
they're
not going to be near us but anything
that would come here would be millions
of years ahead of us not
hundreds not thousands yeah it would
have to be like millions
way ahead right because that's like some
massive distance you have to traverse
right which goes that that so i'm going
to go ahead and say
if they can traverse that distance
they're not biological
which arthur c clarke and some of the
best scientists
[ __ ] all times have said that it said
that no alien life that would come here
that would be
[ __ ] interstellar probably wouldn't
be biological
because it's just too much of a [ __ ]
weakness biology doesn't last that long
you die too soon
it wouldn't mean anything to a [ __ ]
i don't say artificial intelligence but
just like a computer intelligence it
would be nothing for them
to go to sleep for a million years just
nothing
they don't care about time they don't
age yeah
so so that means they wouldn't have to
go fast
but maybe they could go maybe they do go
fast though well maybe they have like
wormhole [ __ ] maybe they have word mold
or [ __ ] warp
type technology that you saw in star
trek they might have that
but when you're talking about these
gigantic craft
like this i got a suspicion that it's
that that's not biological that craft
is the creature that's i think it is
you know that's not a ship with a bunch
of people in it like a flying city
i think that's it that's the creature
it's basically the damn monolith out of
2001.
yeah but yeah you know because i think
people really have a thing that it's
like oh that was a ship and there's like
a lot of people
alien tourists like looking out like the
tour bus you know what i mean
they're dropping by earth to like check
out the [ __ ] yeah
very provincial [ __ ] thinking i mean
when you look in the eight look at back
in the 1800s
of what scientists thought was happening
on mars
you got martian people running around
with [ __ ] mini legs and
umbrellas and dressed like with top hats
on
you know what i mean that they're
dealing with victorian [ __ ]
you know victorian [ __ ] um problems
and [ __ ] no
no that wasn't on mars but they thought
there was life on mars
and they thought there was life on the
moon not that long ago
yeah and it and then that they wore top
hats and had parasols and [ __ ]
just like us yeah yeah yes they were
drinking tea
tea well because of course if they were
martians they must be like all refined
and they so they must be like us because
we're awesome
so obviously they have the same
awesomeness quality they're making
ducks and [ __ ] no
well i think [ __ ] um arthur c
clarke and some of the other scientists
are more likely that no that
biological creatures create artificial
intelligence that
becomes sentient and becomes the next
step in the evolution of life
and then computers and computer
intelligences take over
and they're more intelligent than us
immortal
and are aware and they are alive but
they don't age they're immortal they're
like the gods
and they don't worry about [ __ ] like
money and economies and all these
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that humans are
worried about
and political issues that sounds nice
worried about what gender you are
and [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] about
that man they're just they're they're
machine
intelligences and they just kind of make
themselves into a
these gigantic [ __ ] interstellar
craft and then
then they're living inside of an
internet hooked up with each other
in these craft and so their
intelligences can be anywhere in the
world they're [ __ ] alien souls